[Musica]
qualche ora fa ero in umbria vestita da
dama medievale e tra qualche giorno sarò
in texas tra cowboy and renshaw viaggio
tantissimo realtà già da piccola
viaggiavo tantissimo sono andata a
hogwarts con harry potter sono andata
nella terra di mezzo con bilbo beggins
signore degli anelli e sono persino
andato in africa con il re leone
a furia di viaggiare non ho consumato la
suola delle mie scarpe bensì il nastro
delle videocassette
ho viaggiato tantissimo con la fantasia
alcuni dicono che le passioni si
ereditano dai genitori passioni come
leggere come il viaggiare bene loro sono
i miei genitori
purtroppo per una questione soprattutto
economica non abbiamo potuto viaggiare
tanto insieme
da piccola non ho potuto mai andare
oltre i confini dell'italia ma non ha
giocato un ruolo rilevante solo la
questione economica ha giocato il suo
ruolo anche il fattore fifa infatti
l'unico viaggio che ha fatto mio padre
nella sua vita è stato il viaggio di
nozze
il viaggio in sardegna e pensate che
durante l'intero volo mio padre non ha
fatto altro che prendersi a schiaffi
mia madre lo ricorda sempre mi sarebbe
piaciuto portare mio padre con me almeno
in un viaggio
purtroppo non è stato possibile mio
padre non c'è più da qualche mese ma
sono sicura che lui oggi sarebbe molto
orgoglioso di me
sono sicura che sarebbe orgoglioso
perché oggi sono qui a parlarvi di
viaggi lontani di commistione di culture
sono qui a parlarvi di come superato la
mia zona di comfort e di come tutto
questo mi ha cambiato anche senza
dovermi prendere a schiaffi come faceva
lui come ho fatto qualche anno fa ho
ritrovato questo bigliettino che avevo
scritto quando avevo 8 anni
ve lo leggo da grande voglio scrivere
dei miei viaggi nel mondo è sempre stato
il mio sogno quello di viaggiare e di
scrivere scrivevo tantissimo tuttavia
con anch'io sono stata vittima di tutti
quei discorsi che si fanno sugli scarsi
sbocchi lavorativi con una laurea
nistico e così è influenzata a tutti
questi discorsi o di cio di optare per
una laurea scientifica
ho provato i test di ammissione
vicina fisioterapia e sono ancora qui a
chiedermi perché è ora capirete anche
perché è un pò il destino un po la mia
indole da secchiona meno portato a
superare i testi a mission a
fisioterapia nonostante migliaia di
iscritti che c'erano quell'anno la mia
caparbietà mi ha portato anche ad
arrivare alla laurea mi sono laureata
con il massimo dei voti e con tanto di
lode
come potete vedere qui ma la
fisioterapia non era mai stato il mio
sogno
lo sapevo durante gli anni
dell'università
ho continuato a viaggiare e non solo con
la fantasia
ho viaggiato soprattutto in europa me lo
potevo permettere grazie dei lavoretti
che facevo tuttavia il mio grande sogno
era sempre stato quello di andare a new
york di andare negli stati uniti
un sogno che ho potuto coronare grazie
al regalo del invitate che mi festa di
laurea
immaginate una ragazza che è cresciuta
di fronte ad una distesa di ulivi
verdissimi pugliesi ritrovarsi
all'improvviso circondata dai
grattacieli altissimi di manhattan e con
l'odore costante di hot dog
per me è un sogno ed ero certa che non
sarei più tornato a new york che non
avrebbe più messo piede a new york
quindi cercavo di godere di ogni attimo
di quel viaggio in realtà ancora non
sapevo che sarei tornata ben quattro
volte new york e nel giro di sei anni è
davvero sorprendente
probabilmente vi starete chiedendo cosa
c'è di sorprendente non parlarvi dei
miei viaggi bene lasciate che vi
racconti come questi viaggi sono la
conferma di come una passione si può
trasformare in una professione bene se
sono qui a parlarvi dei miei viaggi lo
devo a quel click che ho fatto poco più
di sei anni fa su apre un blog un click
ingenuo perché alla fine del 2012 ho
aperto il mio blog di viaggi spinta da
l'urgenza di scrivere volevo parlare di
viaggi ma soprattutto volevo scrivere
volevo scrivere anche di me dei miei
viaggi interiori
mi piace chiamarli così ti chiamavo
pensieri in viaggio perché erano appunto
i pensieri che
che viviano venivano fuori dal viaggiare
e dal vivere la mia quotidianità
tuttavia questo diario virtuale per me
doveva rimanere segreto mi vergognavo
tantissimo era quasi una vita parallela
e fa quasi ridere oggi che è tantissima
gente ha un blog e fa di tutto per
ostentarlo per per mostrare il proprio
blog
ma nonostante io me ne vergogno assi e
cercavo di tenerlo nascosto e blog è
venuto fuori e quindi questo spazio
virtuale pian piano ho preso piede nel
web fino a diventare un vero e proprio
lavoro e fino a portarmi a scoprire
quasi tutti i continenti
mi manca l'oceania ma cercherò di
recuperare e a proposito di viaggi
vorrei farvi vivere un pezzettino dei
miei viaggi uno dei viaggi più sul tema
che ho fatto negli ultimi anni del
viaggio in libia quindi vi porto con me
da apulia andiamo in africa per qualche
secondo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
in città
è meravigliosa la namibia
ma io trovo più meraviglia ancora più
clamoroso il fatto che io sia arrivata
fino in a media che sia arrivata fin qui
fin qui dove fino a vedere parte dei
miei sogni realizzarsi questa non sarà
di certo è la cima ma un buon inizio
della scalata perché ha 28 anni ho
potuto viaggiare molto di più di quanto
avrei mai potuto permettermi in una vita
intera
ho potuto scrivere per testate di ogni
genere a cui senza il web non avrei mai
potuto accedere ho scritto un libro
sulla thailandia e io ho avuto il grande
onore di scoprire quasi ogni angolo
della mia puglia e me ne sono innamorata
perché viaggiare mi ha portato ad
apprezzare sempre di più la terra in cui
sono nata in cui sono cresciuta e se
anni fa non avrei potuto assolutamente
immaginare tutto questo non avrei mai
potuto immaginare che la vita mi avrebbe
regalato mi avrebbe fatto regalo simile
quindi il mio messaggio oggi è questo
tirate fuori i vostri sanità cassetto
osate e non abbiate paura del giudizio
altrui
la gente mormora sempre ma in primis lo
facciamo tutti finché qualcuno non ci fa
ricredere
il paradosso è che il mio ex ragazzo mi
prendeva in giro perché non avevo
viaggiato abbastanza
io penso che oggi non lo sarebbe nemmeno
chiedermi di aprire il passaporto per
farvi vedere quanti team di accumulato
finora è una bella soddisfazione ma in
realtà la soddisfazione più grande per
me non è sapere quello che gli altri
pensano di me bensì quello che viaggi mi
hanno regalato quello che viaggi mi
hanno trasmesso mi piace molto una frase
di bruce chatwin in cui mi ritrovo
viaggiare non soltanto è larga la mente
le dà forma perché viaggiare mi ha
aiutato e aiuta noi tutti ad apprendere
l'arte della condivisione a capire che
quei confini che noi reputiamo
invalicabili in realtà sono superabili
sono attraversabili viaggiare mi ha
aiutato ad allargare la mia mente mi ha
aiutato a migliorare il rapporto con gli
altri e rapporto con la nostra terra
in particolare mi ha aiutato tanto
andare in the land ya ho fatto diversi
viaggi in thailandia e inter abbia più
volte mi sono trovata a tavola con
persone provenienti da ogni parte del
mondo
i tailandesi hanno la filosofia della
condivisione
la filosofia che secondo me viene fuori
soprattutto quando si ha a tavola con i
thailandesi e con tutte le persone che
vivono in the land ya mi sono ritrovato
a mangiare con francesi con tedeschi mi
sono ritrovata con sudcoreani e
giapponesi che vivevano a bangkok e che
quindi mi hanno introdotto in questa
loro filosofia e quindi immaginate
tavole piene di piatti coloratissimi
come questi che passano da un commensale
all'altro il cibo così diventa un
collante tra culture estremamente
diverse
e trovo che questo sia bellissimo perché
questo porta a comprendere che le
barriere in realtà non esistono esistono
dei mondi diversi più mondi diversi che
si conoscono che si studiano per
comprendere che alla fine i confini sono
solo sulle mappe geografiche e
l'incredibile è che tutto questo oggi è
possibile con un volo di circa 12 ore da
roma a bangkok
quindi bastano circa 12 ore per poter
vivere esperienze come questa ed è
incredibile se pensiamo che poco tempo
fa viaggiare fino a poco tempo fa
viaggiare era un privilegio per pochi
va da sé che oggi il viaggiatore non è
più un essere unico e speciale
oggi il viaggiatore non è più un essere
che si può sentire privilegiato rispetto
ad altri
a 28 anni io ho viaggiato tanto è vero
ma sicuramente ci sono tantissime
persone che hanno viaggiato molto più di
mike si sono confrontati con molte più
cultura ma questo non importa questo non
importa perché viaggiare non significa
apparire speciali agli occhi degli altri
non si viaggia per piantare delle
bandierine nel mondo si viaggia per
percorrere un sentiero dentro di noi per
scoprire nuovi luoghi e riscoprirsi
pionieri di noi stessi si viaggia per
nutrire l'anima per migliorare se stessi
questo è quello che io cerco sempre in
viaggio e questo è quello che auguro
anche a voi e come ricorda fabrizio
caramagna attraverso il cielo e la terra
come un nomade incontra meraviglie e
colori sconosciuti e rende il i tuoi
amici
questa è la vera ricchezza nella vita
[Applauso]